رفعت اقامه العسكريه الاسرائيليه الحظره
على الحدث الامني الذي وقع على الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه مطلع هذا الاسبوع
وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قتل شخصا تسلل
من الاراضي اللبنانيه وهو المسؤول عن
تنفيذ التفجير الذي وقع في مفترق مجده
جنوب حيفا صباح الاثنين وبحسب المعلومات
فان الشخص تسلل في وقت سابق من هذا
الاسبوع عبر نقطه غير معلومه حتى الان على
الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه ووصل الى
جنوب حيفا حيث زرع العبوه الناسفه في
مفترق مجده ثم استقل سياره وعاد ثانيه الى
الحدود
هذا واكد المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
اصدقائي ادرعي ان قوه من وحده مكافحه
الارهاب قتلا قتلت شخصا تسلل من الاراضي
اللبنانيه وهو مسؤول عن تفجير او تفجيرا
بمفترق مجده جنوب حيفا صباح الاثنين واضاف
ادرعي في تصريح ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحقق
في مسؤوليه حزب الله عن هذه العمليه
انفجرت يوم الاثنين عبط الناسفه بالقرب
مفترق ميكيدو مما ادى الى عصابه مواطن
اسرائيلي بشروخ خطيره حيث على اثر ذلك
واثناء عمليه تمشيط واغلاق الطرق في منطقه
الشمال تم ايقاف السياره حيث شكل
الارهابيه المسلحه الذي كان بداخلها خطرا
على قوات الشباب والشرطه التي قامت
بالتحديد وقتله ويجرى تحقيق موسع حول
العمليه التقريبيه وفي اطارها يتم فحص مدى
تورط منظمه حزب الله الارهابيه فيها
هذا وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان عمليات
التفتيش واسعه جرت وقتها واوصلت الجيش الى
السياره التي استقلها هذا الشخص حيث تبين
انه كان يحمل حزام الناسفا معدا للتشغيل
وهو ما استدعى اطلاق النار عليه وقتله كما
عثر في السياره على اسلحه اخرى وموده يجري
التحقيق في طبيعتها وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه يحقق في مسؤوليه حزب الله عن هذه
العمليه التي وصفها بالخطيره واكد انه
سيبقي قواته على اهبه الاستعداد لتوفير
الحمايه للاسرائيليين
هذا وكانت القناه الرابعه عشره
الاسرائيليه قد نقلت عن رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي هارتي قوله امام جنودا
وضباط في الاحتياط انه يجب الاستعداد لحدث
على جبهات عده تشمل ايران
الينا من راس الناقوره على الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام معنى كذلك من الناقوره على
الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه مدير مكتب
الجزيره مازن ابراهيم ابدا ماركا الياس
كرام وماذا في جديد تطورات هذا الاعلان او
هذه العمليه والتحقيقات الاسرائيليه
بشانها هل ورد اي جديد
نعم بالفعل التقديرات تشير الى ان منفذ
العمليه في مجدو تمكن من التسلل عبر
الحدود اللبنانيه كما يبدو مساء يوم السبت
ووصل الى تلك المنطقه التي تبعد عن الحدود
اللبنانيه مسافه 70 كيلومترا وهذا ما من
شانه بطبيعه الحال ان يصيب هيبه المؤسسه
الامنيه والسياسيه في مقتل على اعتبار ان
المنظومه الامنيه مشدده على الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه لكن مع ذلك يتمكن
هذا الشخص من التسلل والوصول الى مسافه 70
كم في العمق الاسرائيلي وينفذ هذه العمليه
التي وصفت بالخطيره وبالنوعيه لا سيما وان
العبوه الناسفه التي استخدمت هي ليست من
العبوات الناسفه كما تقول الاجهزه الامنيه
المعروفه لديها من المواجهه مع
الفلسطينيين وان هذه العبوات كانت تستخدم
ضد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في جنوب
لبنان عندما كانت اسرائيل تحتل الحزام
الامني في جنوب لبنان في السنوات الماضيه
لكن نشير هنا الى ملك الكثير من الاسئله
ما زالت عالقه لدى اجهزه الامن
الاسرائيليه ولدى المحققين واهمها كما
يبدو كيف وصل منفذ هذه العمليه وكيف تسلل
من اي نقطه وهل تسلل عبر السياج الامني او
الجدار الخرساني الذي يقام في تلك المنطقه
وفي مناطقها مختلفه في القطاعين الغربي
والشرقي للحدود ام ان هنالك ربما يكون نفق
لم تعلم به قوات الامن الاسرائيليه وهذا
المنفذ تسلل منه نشير الى ان اسرائيل كانت
قامت في نهايه عام 2018 بحمله درع الشمال
التي كانت من خلالها قد كشفت عن انفاق
هجوميه لحزب الله اللبناني ودمرت نحو سته
انفاق في عمليه عسكريه امتدت على اكثر من
شهر كامل المعلومات المتوفره هو ان منفذ
العمليه تسلل من الحدود وكما اشرنا وصل
الى مجدو ونفذ العمليه التفجيريه ثم كما
يبدو استقل سياره وعاد مره اخرى الى
المنطقه الحدوديه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول
المنفذ العمليه اراد تنفيذها عمليه كبيره
وضخمه وانه عثر بحوزته على حزام ناسف مما
استدعى قوه اليمان وحده مكافحه الارهاب
لاطلاق النار عليه وقتله وربما هذا سيجعل
يصعب ربما مهمه في تقصي الحقائق والوصول
الى الحقيقه والى كل ملابسات ما جرى لكن
من الواضح ان هذه العمليه كما اشرت تصيب
هيبه المؤسسه الامنيه والسياسيه في مقتل
نشير الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان اوصى
بحسب
المستوى السياسي للرد عسكريا رغم انه لا
يوجد هنالك اي ربط حتى الان بين حزب الله
ومنفذ هذه العمليه لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي
اوصى بعمليه رد عسكري لكن يدحرون تقول بان
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير دفاعي
وافبح هذه
العمليه واوقفاها وهذا ربما ما يفسر امام
ايضا ان المستوى السياسي هو من اراد ان
يبقي هذا التعتيم الاعلامي على فحوى وتف
اصيل